a quote you cited about elon's really
stood out to me I forget uh who was from
but inside the man he's still there as a
child the child standing in front of his
dad that was Tallulah his second wife
and she's great uh she's an English
actress they've been married twice
actually and Tallulah said that's just
him from his childhood he's a drama
addict Kimball says that as well and
I asked why and he said and Tallulah
said
you know for him love and family are
kind of associated with those
psychological torments and in many ways
he'll Channel I mean Tallulah would be
with him in
2008 when the company was going back or
whatever it may have been or later
and he would be so stressed he would
vomit and then he would Channel things
that his father had said use phrase as
his father had said to him
and so she told me deep inside the man
is this man-child still standing in
front of his father
to a degree is that true for many of us
do you think I think it's true but in
many different ways I'll say something
personal which is I was blessed and
perhaps it's a bit of a downside too but
the fact that I had the greatest father
you could ever imagine and mother they
were the kindest people you'd ever want
to meet I grew up in a magical place in
New Orleans my dad was an engineer an
electrical engineer and
you know he was always kind
perhaps
I'm not quite as driven or as crazed I
don't have to prove things so I get to
write about Elon Musk I get to write
about you know Einstein or Steve Jobs or
Leonardo da Vinci who as you know was
totally torn by demons and had different
difficult childhood situations not even
legitimized by his father so sometimes
those of us who are lucky enough to have
really gentle sweet childhood
we grow up with fewer demons but we grow
up with fewer drives and we end up maybe
being Boswell and not being Dr Johnson
we end up being the Observer not being
the doer and so I always respect those
who are in the arena I don't you know
you don't see yourself as a man in the
arena I've had a gentle sweet career
and I've got to cover really interesting
people but I've never shot off a rocket
that might someday get to Mars I've
never moved us into the era of electric
vehicles I've never stayed up all night
on the factory floor
I don't have quite
those
either the drives or the
uh addiction to risk I mean elon's
addicted to risk he's addicted to
Adventure me if I see something that's
risky I spend some time calculating okay
upside down side here uh but that's
another reason that people like Elon
Musk get stuff done
and people like me write about the Elon
musks